[Music]
there sits the only King I mean to bend
my needle
just a little bit of Edward the fourth
and Rob too and you know Rob is in some
ways the early Edward the fourth trazan
you know someone to King's Landing to
swear fealty to the new king after
Richard of York is killed his teenage
son Edward becomes the Duke of York and
leads his armies and wins several
victories over the Lancaster's while
still a teenager and a very young man
his grace summons me to King's Landing
I'll go to King's Landing they're not
alone call the burners Edward the fourth
or the future Edward the fourth this is
only 18 years old young guy he's
passionate impulsive and a brilliant
military commander he was never defeated
on the field of battle and Tywin
Lannister's whole problem with Robb
Stark is he keeps winning stock went
risk marching on Casterly Rock until
he's at full force he's a boy and he's
never lost a battle he'll risk anything
at any time
and of course like Rob Edward married
unwisely to a woman he met while on
campaign I don't want to marry the Frey
girl
[Music]
the difference between Robb Stark and
Edward the fourth is Edward the fourth
successfully overthrows Henry the sixth
and becomes king where Robb Stark gets
killed at the red wedding the red
wedding man it's the iconic episode
right it's almost too crazy to be true
except George's said he was taking his
inspiration from real history george RR
martin has taken several different
events specifically drawing from
scottish history and mixed them up
together to create the red wedding
scottish history is an amazing source
for all of this because it's one of the
most incredibly bloody histories of any
country that I've ever ever studied he
was looking at the black dinner of 1440
held at the core of the boy King James
ii of scotland the black dinner occurred
when the king of scotland was having a
dispute with the black Douglass's the
lord of Douglas was a young man 18 or 19
years old kind of a Robb Stark figure
and he brought his even younger brother
with him and they had a marvelous feast
and everybody was having great old time
but then when the feast was over a
single drum began to play just boom boom
boom
[Music]
men rushed in grab the L and his brother
dragged him outside and beheaded them
now the other half of it of course was
the Glencoe massacre which was a few
centuries later the Campbells came to
the town of Glencoe which was a
macdonald town and they they stayed
overnight with the McDonald's but there
were these bowls of hospitality in
Scotland that were very time-honored and
obeyed just as in Westeros the
McDonald's fed to Campbell's and they
gave them water and they gave them
shelter from the storm and then in the
middle of night their guests rose up
from their beds and started killing
every McDonald they can get their hands
on you know guests slaughtering their
hosts in case of the red wedding I
reversed that and their regards it's
those two incidents I blended together
to make the red wedding I'm a brother of
the Nights Watch
I don't know what I have left to give
you you can give me the north even if I
wanted to on the busted snow kneel
before me lay your sword at my feet
pledge me your service in your rise
again as John Stark Lord of Winterfell
having Westeros is set in a feudal
society ask Jon Snow if this is a feudal
world who's gonna tell you of course it
is he's a bastard he's born outside it
its King led there are noble houses the
idea of your birthright is potent a
firstborn heir male heir is the most
important person so Robb Stark is the
most important person in the stark
family in the very first episode you see
the stark children lining up to Greeks
Robert Baratheon well they're lined up
in order of age and gender
so Robb Stark used the oldest boy as
first thence onset is second Arya is
third but she's late and bran is
standing in her place and she shoves him
out of the way
because she's the one that's supposed to
be there so in that that very basic
sense we're talking about an hour a
stoker attic world in which your birth
is in a sense your destiny yes Westeros
is a feudal system although it's a
feudal system of course complicated by
White Walkers and Dragons I do not go
full feudal but I have a quasi feudal
system where there are landed Knights
and awards to have castles who swear
fealty to the king so there's this
network of obligations you have lower
lords like Eddard Starks fossils in the
north all those high Ned Stark hoster
Tully people like Roose Bolton who kind
of chafe a little that they have to bend
the knee no more stops to balance great
- must have been torture following that
stupid boy all over the country he
ignored my advice at every turn
that's relationship of having to serve a
lord an overlord militarily as well as
support them in other matters it was
very common in the Middle Ages